Curiosity for me is always about asking the first and the second questions.
What is it and then why is it like that?
People are always amazed when I talk about being an anthropologist at Intel 'cause...
...they can't imagine what that job would possibly entail.
Knowing what people do with technology today...
...can help you make the technology fit tomorrow.
You have to know why people love the things they already have...
...to invent the next generation of things they're gonna want.
I'm always interested in,  "Is there a different way of thinking about an object?"
How do you let people have a moment of seeing something...
...deeply familiar from a really different perspective?
How do you create the moment when someone can see something for the first time?
And curiosity is about what you can make people...
...think about, you know, what you can make possible for them.
I think curiosity is not just about observing things, it's about being changed by them.